hello everybody hello hello sorry for being a little late
today um i didn't have much time to set up because i just
got back recently because i took dad out on a shopping trip
yeah we went shopping um i decided to spoil him give him
like an early um an early christmas gift yes the field is
here, Mr. J.
I will beat Sandsfield.
I have been every iteration of Sands and Sandsfield will not
win.
I beat all your crossovers.
I have triumphed every single one of the Sands crossovers or
Sands games or Sands in general from the OG Undertale.
Sandsfield not defeat me I will beat Sandsfield no matter
the genre rhythm or undertale I guess those are the only two
genres I played of Sands games but uh Sandsfield is no
different I shall win I will be on top the Sands multiverse
will not beat me shall conquer every universe of sands let
me drink my water real quick after that right
one george thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
part of crowd fun for dad's throwing the super chat thank
you thank you so for those who don't follow me on twitter um
i took dad out to a uh to a shopping trip uh so uh uh So I
bought him a really cute outfit.
Literally, like, I saw the outfit.
Okay, so I saw the outfit.
And I was just like, I went straight to the cashier, paid
for it, put him in the outfit, and then continue my shopping
trip.
And so let me grab the photo real quick.
Yeah, I just paid for that first and then continued, like,
shopping.
wear this today is my okay it's his day but but it's also my
money and so i deserve this so for those who want to see uh
what i bought so he has his own little goffield suit too so
yeah this is yeah priorities i saw this i was like i must
have it and then he went straight to the cat section too and
was digging around cat toys um i did like i blurred like the
stuff on the left because it was literally me meowawana and
i felt like that's weird to tweet that i'll say it here no i
i mean it's legal here but still i was just like meowawana
and i was like what the fuck so it's like weed for cats i
was like what Like, bro, cats can go get high.
Is it cat dip or, like, weed?
I don't, I didn't look at it.
I was just like, meow, wana.
Anyway, that's why I blurred it because I was like, that's
weird.
I'm going to blur in case people are like, what the fuck is
your dog doing next to meow, wana?
So I blurred it.
Yeah, that good shit.
apparently anyway so yeah i bought this and i instantly like
paid for it and then continued shopping oh that's what
catnip is i don't know i don't own a cat so i don't know
what catnip actually does does to cats um i thought it was
just a little treat like food or some shit i don't know i
never owned a cat before but he also got this and and i got
him a little couch i just thought you know uh when i first
had dad um uh my parents gifted me like a jack like a big
like not big sorry like a like a red couch similar to this
one so i was like oh that's cute i mean he doesn't fit um
the red couch is gone gone it was like so fucking old like
he doesn't even fit on that couch because it was when he was
like a little puppy i was like oh they sell couches here too
so i was like so i got him a little couch look at that he's
such a Look how tiny this little sofa is.
Isn't that cute?
I don't even have a couch.
But my dog has a couch.
That's so fucking sad.
I don't even own furniture.
Like, I barely own any furniture.
But I bought my dog a couch, though.
Like, that's money well spent.
Not gonna lie.
I don't need furniture.
But I think my dog does.
It's perfectly sized for my dog.
It's so cute.
yeah we went on a little shopping trip me and my dog spent
like 300 200 um i was like was it 300 or 200 um i got one of
my cars to climb and that was a little worrying but it was
the it was from that stupid fucking bank i hate that bank so
much anyway i have to use my other card because i was like
bro it's 200 like um no i didn't call my bank because i was
like why the Fuck did you decline?
There's a lot of money on that account.
I was like, I was like, there's no way the account is empty.
There's a lot of money in that account.
So I was just like, how did I get declined?
So I don't know.
Fuck that.
I hate that bank so much.
Anyway, it was like two, like I spent 200, I mean, 200
Canadian Buccaroonies on this dog today.
So it's like, I don't know.
Maybe it's like 10 American dollars.
I can't tell I heard the American dollar currency is also
falling so yeah I mean that's bad because America the
economy sort of relies on American dollar so I feel like
that's sort of bad especially for Canada because our also
our currency has been falling for a while so not yay I was
like not yay guys not yay because the rest of the world is
so Because, um, I don't, okay, here, here's a little fun
history, uh, fact.
Um, in the past, currency was tied to gold because, um,
because that was the easiest way to balance things to, like,
I guess, currency conversion and a way to, like, what's it
called, stabilize, like, the dollar.
So everything was connected to gold.
And then America came along and was like, fuck that shit.
We didn't, fuck God.
currency and then they like they uh they basically got rid
of the gold stat it was called the gold standard and they
got rid of that because they're like we're the center of the
world and then now we follow uh now we follow the american
dollar and the american dollar is sort of falling right now
and i don't like that i i i'm a little concerned now
not sure if it's the best decision in hindsight uh yeah if
we go down everyone goes down with us that's true that's
true that's true america does like to do that um as as
america's neighbor we have experienced that quite a lot to
be fair uh but hey hey we get to be in the World Cup,
though.
Canada gets to be in the World Cup!
Yeah!
At least we get to be included in the pros and the cons.
We'll take those.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Woo!
Welcome!
Fun fact, most of the presents on the dollar bills were
completely against the Federal Reserve.
Thank you for the super chat thank you thank you yeah we
ride or die baby like currency's fucked but world cup whoo
i'm sorry my country is like this um anyway uh so yeah it's
a little a little concerning so she'll have a lot of
american dollars in my bank account right now but at least
they'll always be better than the Canadian dollar at least
that's my positive here Canadian dollar at least with the
American dollar falling the Canadian dollar is also falling
and I still have my American Bukaroonies in my account so I
should really start getting gold I should maybe you know
maybe the people are right you know how they're like no
don't trust the banks just buy gold maybe I should have done
that maybe Maybe, maybe, maybe I should have listened to the
tinfoil ads.
Oh,
Lord, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The USD was so backed by Go until 1971.
The economy going bad can be traced back to that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Lord, thank you, thank you.
Anyway, it's time to play Bad Monday Simulator.
If you remember this game, we played it on Halloween.
accidentally because we were just looking around for guard
field games and we were never able to beat um bad monday
simulator because it was a very very very bad monday we got
to we found out there was a phase three and that was when i
was like not today but today is finally the day guys
remember i said not today well today is that day also i need
to know if sound guy is with us today um because this game
can get really loud so i gotta make sure uh everything is
balanced properly hey guys let's watch some lore um we're
playing the actual version of the game this time instead of
the um instead of the one that like i don't know like some
random garfield website stole off the internet so i found
the original one so i heard they like updated it more so
they had they added lore videos and everything so let's
watch this let's find figure out the lore of uh what's it
called under yeah the world of undergarf long ago a week on
earth it only lasted six days oh my god people monsters
cartoons everyone lived in harmony oh that sounds nice one
faithful day a calamity fell weeks became a day no my days
were poor began to change.
There was more anger.
Choconflictora upon the earth for hundreds of years.
Monchi, Indiana.
Garfield?
They say there exists a magical place.
Are you in here?
This isn't funny.
A hidden and special place without war or strife.
Oh my god, am I playing normal?
This is a Monday.
I can't believe I have to play as fucking Nerval.
How could the world be so cruel to me?
This bitch is fake as hell.
Undergarf!
Alright, there we go.
There we go.
Subscribe to Lumpy.
Alright, let's go to this one.
Okay, let's go all the way from beginning.
Meet the cast of Undergarf.
Alright, who lives here?
Johnny!
Welcome newcomers to the world.
Where is my pipe?
Alright, so he's flowery.
Goat mom.
Welcoming under...
Managed a small vacation resort at the entrance to the
underground.
Limba block.
Can't remember where his house is, so lives pretty much
anywhere.
Oh, the forgetful phantom roommate.
Sansfield, lazy, lovable group.
Doesn't think he's overweight.
Rather, he is under tall.
Usually hang out with odorous.
Oh!
Oedorous!
Sovereign skeletal buddy.
Friendly, consider yourself a superhero with a power to make
people.
People smile.
Arlene.
Patroids the farmlands with her biker gang, protecting the
citizens and upholding justice.
Pookie.
Sentient stuffed.
Oh, he's a dummy.
Garfield's favorite stuffed toy given life.
Joke.
J.D.
Gaster.
Okay, that's good.
I like that.
Alph Liz, the doctor of the underground, performed secret
experiments on the side.
Stern medical professional.
Uh, way a ton.
Healthcare assistant android.
Does that...
Oh wait, what does he look like when he's hot, though?
Oh my god, no!
No!
No, it's Blinky!
Way a ton's new body.
No!
Not Blinky!
Okay, DadGore, and finally, is that me?
Normal, oh my god, why do I look like that?
Only recently came under...
Oh, shit!
Doesn't seem to have fused with...
No, I'm so sad.
Why do I look like that?
I look so ugly.
I want to see the Monday shit.
Oh, shit.
That's, oh my god.
Nirmal, you okay, girl?
You okay?
Alright, this time.
Yeah, he's ready to throw hands.
Before the battle.
Alright, more lore.
It's a scratching post.
Nirmal on the catnip.
Yeah, it was completely annihilated.
No, Nirmal's a dude.
Nirmal's always been a dude.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Sonsfield!
I dream you never showed up here.
We had a good thing going on.
But in typical Nerman fashion, you've ruined everything.
I try to tell everyone should kick you up.
But they convinced me to let you to stay.
You were just a cute little kid and after all.
Now they're all gone and I'm stuck with this mess to clean
up.
I hate these.
right.
Almost as much as I hate Mondays.
That's right.
I know your true nature.
Didn't think you could become more annoying, but you found a
way.
Tell you what, I'll show you a little mercy.
Give up, get out of here, and don't come back.
Normal.
That's your answer?
You really think you can beat me?
He knows.
Nirmal is secretly Monday!
I'm gonna enjoy teaching you the pecking order.
Oh my god, I'm filled with determination right now.
It's too bad I'm fucking Nirmal.
Show me what you got!
He's gonna have a bad Monday!
Let me guess.
Not done yet.
You sure you want to lose again?
Yeah, it's going to be hard to cheer for normal now.
Knowing that I'm actually normal.
It's going to be very hard, guys.
I thought I was someone else.
But I just had to be normal.
Could have been anyone.
else but it just had to be normal of all the characters i
had to be all right all right so is sound guy um sound guy
alive or any of our mods alive oh all right let us all right
let me make sure that everything's set up here see uh
w-a-s-d w z what is it called z x what comes from okay i'm
just trying to see like what the controls are before we play
all right there you go yeah no i have to swap all right no
we're not guys i saw like there's i don't start with one hp
and no items i was like that's crazy
yeah no we're doing normal guys or no that's No, guys.
Alright.
You know what?
Let's go in with a prayer.
Nirmal.
Oh, that makes more sense in context.
What did I get?
Nirmal was visited by the pasta fairy.
She left the present.
You got a noodle!
Oh.
Oh, there you go.
Where is my pipe?
Oh.
okay okay this is all right okay goodbye of course the first
one where is that's the first one i got oh my god forgot how
to play this game guys this is not looking so good oh okay i
remember odi okay uh let's grab oh my god so much noodles
okay we're gonna eat a noodle How much is a noodle?
Okay.
Oh, that was 15.
Okay, it's OD time.
Watch out.
Oh, that was 15.
Oh, I forgot how to play this.
Okay.
Nice.
Bye.
Oh!
Yeah, it's almost there.
All right, 30.
Oh, no!
No!
The poopers!
That's okay.
It's okay.
It's just it's it's warm up guys.
It's warm up It's just warm up actually wait Okay I don't
know how to back out Someone try to do okay, of course.
Oh, fucking okay.
Okay.
It's okay Okay I'm gonna pray Nirmal pray.
Oh, hello.
What do I get this time?
Is it more nudas?
Oh, nice.
I got some lasagna!
Yeah!
Oh.
Where is my pipe?
Fire!
Oh, goodbye.
It's okay.
It's warm up, guys.
It's warm up.
It's still warm up.
I shall pray.
Maybe this time it won't just be...
Okay, okay, cool.
You know, you know, that's fine.
Where is my fight?
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I'm...
There you go.
See, look at that.
See, I'm getting better.
I'm getting better.
Oh!
I almost missed, but that's fine.
That's fine.
I looked at chat for one second.
What?
Okay.
Woo!
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, 31.
That's a good attack.
Oh, I don't remember.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, no.
That's not nice.
Not nice.
Okay.
Um, I could do another hit.
30.
We're halfway there.
Oh.
See, look at that.
I'm getting better, guys.
Okay, halfway, we're halfway.
Oh, God.
No!
Oh, all right.
I think I got you a lasagna.
I think it's lasagna time.
100 HP.
Okay, good, good, good.
It's an OD.
That's almost messed up there.
Oh, oh, he's getting closer.
Oh, no, not again.
Where is my pipe?
Oh, God.
Okay, okay, okay.
That's, you know, 20 damage, 20 damage.
I'll take those.
That's the lowest I ever got.
Oh,
my God.
Okay, okay.
I got that disoriented there.
27, 27, phase two?
Phase two?
Why can he...
Oh, no.
Oh
Okay, I Look, um I I just don't know I don't know I there's
no excuse.
I I don't have any excuse to scream Look, it's just like
just stuff happens I'll pray Maybe prank will help.
Oh, yay!
See, I told you.
Prank.
I told you, prank does help.
Okay, here you go.
It's a tutorial.
Where is my fun?
Yeah, I definitely got you in the lasagna here.
Oh, oh, yeah, yeah, no, I definitely need a lasagna.
Om, yom, yom, yom.
I swear to God, if it gives me another...
Where is my pipe after this?
Thank God.
As long as it's not pipe.
Ah!
Okay, that's on me.
That's on it.
I messed up there a little.
Just a little.
Jesus Christ.
Why are you kicking it closer?
Okay.
There you go.
I think I activate phase two here.
He's in phase two.
And then they're going to give me a sheep's red.
Oh.
Spaghetti.
Look.
Yay!
Oh!
Okay, this is easy.
Like, that's bullshit!
Help!
Oh my god, why can't I just get that?
That's okay.
Oh, that's that's fine.
So hard.
I don't know what to do it's it goes so fast okay that's
fine that's fine it's like z z z z it just tempts me so much
you know like you see and you just want to sleep the sky
feels things you know
it's okay just i just stubbed my toe oh i did
Very, very hard.
Oh, okay, that's cool.
Okay, I decided to spray down juices a lot longer than
usual.
Oh, my God.
Okay, it's fine.
Everything is fine.
I'm still alive.
It's lasagna time.
Oh, my God.
One HP and a dream.
No.
Where is my fight?
Don't you hate it when you just stub your toes like five
times in a row?
Oh my god, that's...
Oh, I've never had that happen before.
See guys, I can improve.
It is possible.
See guys, I do learn.
Okay.
Just stay down.
Are you fucking?
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's just Odie things, you know?
It's not give.
I just wanted to give Odie a bone.
Okay, stay where I am.
Or I'll stay where I am this time.
Oh, thank God it's a sheep.
Thank God.
It's okay.
Just sheep things.
Goddamn stupid bitch.
Guys.
guys i'm i'm moving up and down and i don't know
i don't know i am i swear to god i am moving up and down
yeah it's okay spaghetti spaghetti
Oh, oh, no, no, no.
Oh, I remember this is Toho Tap.
Okay.
All right.
Phase three.
Oh, my God.
You know what?
I'll pray.
I think I'll need I'll need God to help me here Oh Oh oh I
forgot Oh I forgot about this
Okay To be fair that was like the second time I've ever seen
that move You don't understand you don't understand This was
the second time I saw that move Okay, I got confused
Okay, I think I just don't hit him during like the other
phase the second phase Because like I just have to wait
until he gets full HP and I'll activate his third phase.
I'm pretty sure Okay, I know we'll pray the second time Woo
Okay Cody that's right muscle memory bitch I'm a better
Garfield than you are.
Oh, that's fine.
Just a couple of HP.
Just 10 HP.
It's 5.
Oh, no.
Where is my pipe?
That's right.
I'm ranked higher than you on the Garfield tier list.
There you go.
Okay, one more hit.
Oh, no.
Cookie gasters.
No!
Oh!
There goes my HP.
Oh, ho!
There goes all my HP.
It's on you, Sam.
Bum.
Goodbye, HP.
I can just stay here.
Nice.
It's okay.
I triggered the second phase on this.
Never mind.
One last pipe.
Where is my pipe?
Oh, nice.
Zero hits.
Don't worry about that lasagna I ate earlier.
That never happened.
Please be sheep.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Yay!
Okay.
Are you fucking?
Okay, it's okay.
I pray.
Spaghetti!
Yeah!
Oh,
that's good.
Okay.
Oh my god.
That's a lot of lasagna.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
That's actually huge.
That's actually...
I did not realize she gave me, like, an entire year's supply
of lasagna.
That's actually crazy.
Okay.
I pray.
Maybe I'll get more lasagna.
More lasagna!
This is a run.
What did she give me?
I got spaghetti!
Spaghetti!
All right, there we go.
Okay, Toho.
This is it.
I have so much lasagna.
Oh my god.
I'm getting cross-eyed from all these notes.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
No hits.
I stolen.
I stolen the food from my neighbors.
We should be fine now.
Okay, that's a lot of HP.
That's...
a lot that's a lot of HP okay it's okay we're still it's
still salvageable I still have my lasagna oh my god what did
any of that meant I don't what the fuck is that
what does orange blue mean ah oh not good
okay orange blue don't it's okay i'm lasagna
okay i don't remember my under tail
what the fuck okay it's okay
Okay, that is good.
That's actually easy.
All right.
Wait, that's easy.
That one's easy.
I got this one Okay.
One, two.
Oh, God.
Okay, I have, I still have lasagna on my side.
I'm halfway.
What?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Sans, how could you?
I mean, I did kill you in every version.
But how could...
That's so messed up.
That's actually so messed up.
They're working together now.
There it is.
Who gave Garfield a gun?
Who gave...
Who gave this cat a gun?
It's like those AI videos.
again.
Who AI Garfield?
Who took my gun?
Okay.
What do you mean, Joki?
Don't you forget?
He always had a gun.
It's the best I've done against Gastropuki.
Where is my life?
This iconic gun It's on almost every comic strip, Doki How
could you forget?
Oh my, I'm I hit every letter I hit every single letter
possible Spaghetti die Colorcastle was like No hit run!
It was you Okay
You did this.
Why is it still?
Oh my god, it never even collapsed.
Okay, now it started fucking moving.
Are you fucking kidding me?
That should trigger it.
Nice.
Oh, please don't me sleep.
Please give me sheep, sheep, sheep, sheep, sheep.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Nizania.
Yay.
Oh, here we go.
Things like...
Sheep tab.
Okay, that's fine.
That's 5 HP.
And then I pray.
Pray to the gods.
No!
That's- that's okay.
That's okay.
Just- that means I just gotta do it one more time.
Oh, no.
No.
Okay.
Spaghetti.
Guys, I don't think this is the run, guys.
This may or may not be the run.
Okay.
Pray.
Pray to the pastor, lords.
Oh, that's okay.
That's fine.
That's why I still have one more spaghetti, guys.
spaghetti.
I have one more spaghetti in a dream.
It's all on me.
I get cross-eyed playing this part.
This one is actually so fucking crazy.
I actually get cross-eyed.
But maybe the past gods will smile.
Yay!
It's a fairy!
Spaghetti!
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
The Pass-A-Fairy Graceme with Spaghetti!
Oh!
Okay, um, thank God she gave me spaghetti, guys.
Thank God I...
Thank God I got spaghetti.
Oh, shit.
Are you forgetting this one's the don't move?
Okay, that's...
Spaghetti!
That was not cool.
What is this?
Oh!
Whoops.
Oh, whoops.
Oh.
Spaghetti!
At least I still have my spaghetti, guys.
Guys, don't worry, I'll eventually make my move.
I wish it just gives me that six times in a row.
That would have been nice.
Okay, nice.
I finally got, like, a freebie.
The 28 damage freebie.
Oh, shit.
I got confused there.
A lot of things were happening on my screen, guys.
Bye-bye.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
I dodged that.
She has a gun.
He has a fucking gun.
He shot me.
Where is my butt?
Okay, I can't believe that.
Like, how?
There you go.
I got touched by the cloud, but there we go.
That's it.
I'm angry.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
His toe touched me.
That's okay.
I just stubbed my toe on Odis.
On Odis' toe.
We both suffered today.
That's okay.
Lasagna.
You know how I eat spaghetti?
I don't know how to eat lasagna.
Okay.
That's cool.
I'll just stay here.
Moving was a mistake.
Fuck me, I guess.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh, I wish they just gave me that and Odie.
Like, seven times in a row.
Instead of where is my pipe?
Where is my pipe?
There we go.
As long as...
Okay, it's fine Was
it fine?
It wasn't fine at all
Lasagna Past the thing Lasagna Yeah It's okay
It's okay.
We live We got lasagna We got lasagna
Okay, that means we can tank it we can tank a lot Oh my god,
we still tank it guys Oh my god a fucking course
Where is my butt?
God
I live, bitch.
Right in the center.
Symmetry.
Come on, give me another OD.
Give me another OD after this.
You know you'll want to.
Come on.
Come on, Sandfield.
Don't you tired?
Don't you want to rest?
Sand still.
Oh, never mind.
a mistake guys always stay moving are you not where is my
fight
okay that's just ah do i eat i think i should eat i'm gonna
eat just in case i'm gonna make full hp for the last for the
phase and then They're going to give me an OD.
I'm okay.
It wasn't an OD, but it's okay.
It's okay.
We pray.
We pray to the pasta fairy.
All right.
That's all right.
Oh my.
Oh, yeah, no, that's lasagna time.
That's a lasagna.
Oh.
Okay.
The past of gods will pray upon me.
Oh, that's okay.
That's 10 HP.
That's okay.
That's all right.
But, please.
Oh, oh, oh.
Maybe the past.
Pesta?
God damn it.
Stop fucking throwing rocks at a cat!
Stop throwing raft rocks at the local cat, guys!
It's not helping me!
You're not helping!
God, oh, this is the first time I've, like, got hit by
those.
It just makes me so cross-eyed.
Yeah.
Oh.
Okay, it's time.
Left.
Oh, God.
It's centered.
I think I can risk this one.
Oh, that's so risky.
Oh, that is so...
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I got to eat.
I got to eat.
I'm going to eat lasagna.
I have to eat one.
That was...
fucking risky of me to do.
But I was like praying the fact that it's not Sans with a,
it's not Garfield with a gun.
Okay, that's bullshit!
Okay, that one was bullshit.
I gotta eat the spaghetti.
I couldn't make it at the time.
It was not wanted to.
Oh, thank God.
Freebie, Tad.
All right.
At least I got the freebie.
They felt bad for me.
I feel bad for me, too.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my.
I didn't see the bottom left.
I didn't see it.
Okay.
Not Sand's with a...
Not Garfield with a gun.
Not Garfield.
Oh.
I said...
I risked it all.
I didn't think that he would give me Garfield with my gun.
I was like, there's no way.
There's no way he's gonna come in with a Glock.
There's no way.
Oh, I'm not doing okay right now.
I swear to God, he might as well be aimbotting.
He might as well.
Oh, is it in order?
It triggers at half health.
Okay, that's good to know.
Now I know he'll always come back.
Okay, fuck you, Odie.
You know, I'll risk it.
Risk, baby.
I take that Gamba.
Gamba time.
Okay, now I take the lasagna time.
Alright, there you go.
Oh my god, fucking course.
Are you fucking?
Okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
It's just one damage.
It's practically nothing for you, Doki.
Look how healthy you are.
Barely a spruce.
Not even a bruise.
All right.
One more hit.
Oh, God.
Okay, that was on me.
Oh, ha ha ha ha.
No, I got a spaghetti that.
That was on me.
That was poor positioning.
His butt of scratch.
All right.
Now that I will trigger it.
Snappy wappy time
Okay, at least it gave me a cheat first
Pray What's that?
What the fuck?
Oh
Okay, that...
Oh, yeah, a fucking...
Okay, cool.
Oh my god, that threw me off.
Oh my god, that blast threw me off.
I was like, what the fuck?
It didn't even matter!
He can't die here face still!
What do you mean that with some fucking move?
Okay, pray tab.
My toes tingle?
Oh, okay, that's...
Okay, all right, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, God.
I'm a lot of spaghetti.
Thanks, Gabe.
Thanks.
Good to know that stuff.
Blood circulating in my toes.
That's good to know.
Very cool.
I'm glad to know I can still feel my toes.
Oh, God.
I hate this.
Okay.
We gotta pray for this.
one we have no food now we are we're starving and we're
homeless we need to pray to the lords to the pastor gods
please pastor gods oh oh okay oh okay
thank you pastor gods let's get to know that i'm starving
still maybe please I'm so hugged okay oh oh that's okay cool
oh okay
that one I know all right maybe this you know fourth time is
the charm oh that's you know what that's just that that's
all right
oh that is not okay anymore oh
past past past the past the map Passed up, fairy?
Oh, oh, nice.
Nice.
Okay, this is where Sands comes in with a gun, like, or
Garfield comes in with a gun right here after this.
Um, so, doesn't matter whatever happens.
Oh, that's cool.
I guess she's on a break right now.
oh he's paralyzed this is it oh my toes tingled okay guys it
was not it
guys it was apparently not it apparently that was not you
know what maybe if i pray yay finally If I pray, he'll get
beat up.
Where is my pipe?
Oh my god, I got hit by the pipe.
I didn't think it was possible.
It's okay.
It's just half HP.
Just half HP.
Oh god.
29.
Woo!
Oh, just 50 HP things.
Jumpy jump.
And then Odie.
Okay.
I'll do a hit here.
And then...
Oh, nice.
And I'll eat pasta.
No, actually, I'll pray.
I'm going to pray.
Because there's a chance.
Oh, God.
Okay, wait, I need to focus this.
There's no way.
Oh, my God.
I got to eat.
to eat oh god he is spaghetti pizza will never be doing this
to you dr cranberry thank you for the magenta soup thank you
thank you okay i'll pray after this well i have i should
know i shouldn't pray i should like hit him after this oh my
the one time the one He actually hits an odi on me.
Okay, then he goes Nap-D time.
Say, lasagna.
Touched my toes and I have to go in a coma.
Don't you hate it when that happens?
You stub your toe and then you're, like, hospitalized for
life.
Fucking sucks, bro.
Oh, fucking curse, guys.
Stop.
Please stop throwing rocks at Garfield.
Hold X?
I'm using...
I... I was looking at chat.
I was looking at chat.
I can't because I'm using WASD.
I'm using WASD so I can't do that.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
It's okay.
We stop praying.
it's okay it's okay we can still pray pastor fairy it's been
three turn oh okay okay that's all right okay it's okay
pastor fairy it's okay i know you're a very busy woman but
perhaps you would like to come down oh oh okay
oh that's she's so busy guys she's so oh yeah look like it
takes her four to five business days to respond to me she's
such a busy woman
oh past the ferry oh it's snowing ice it's oh nice okay
Oh my god, I've just made it.
You know, it's alright.
I still...
She'll respond to me, guys.
Yeah!
She responded!
Spaghetti!
Yeah, see, I told you.
I told you she wasn't ghosting me, guys.
I knew...
I know her.
I told you.
You guys were like, bro, you don't even know her, man.
She's trying to...
She's, like, avoiding your cars.
Like, no!
I know her!
Bro!
I swear I went to a birthday party, guys.
I know I didn't take any photos, but I swear it happened.
Oh, my God.
That was not good.
A 50-miss guy.
She had an emergency, and that's why she wasn't taking my
cars.
You don't even know, you little bro.
Oh, no.
more spaghetti more spaghetti yeah i still have what oh my
oh my god what's going
oh my god what the fuck was going on there i went through
like 20 phases i swear okay all these are like apparently
like scripted too I remember this I remember the pattern for
this right here I'm halfway all right nice I know the script
I wrote it I'm you this way and it's like here and it's like
here.
Oh my god, look at that.
I'm you.
It's like I wrote the script or something.
Oh my god, nice.
It's a freebie.
Oh, it's the other jaw now.
Okay, I'm next one is Garfield with a gun.
So I'm going to eat the spaghetti real quick Just in case
Because I don't trust myself against Garfield with a gun Oh,
it's not Okay, I lost I lost the script I lost the script
But I still made it
Okay, now it's Garfield with a gun Oh, God Oh, oh, ah, ah
Ah, ah, ah
You'd react the same way if a cat blows a gun on you.
You can't tell me if a cat fucking runs up to you with a
gun, you would not get shot.
Come on.
You'll all get shot by a cat with a gun.
Where is my butt?
Oh, wait, that's how you do the snow thing.
Okay, I figured it out.
Whoa, whoa, that's angry.
Um, um, I was just, you know.
Like, my groove was thrown.
Okay.
This is safe.
I should eat up spaghetti just in case I
Looked at chat Oh Let me grab a lasagna real quick.
Yeah, I look I looked at chat for one second
Is my pipe.
Oh, I really wanted that pipe guys Okay, this is my worst
rush yet all
right that's good that's fine i'll
just stay here things will be okay see look at that
untouchable oh god please don't get closer to me please
don't get closer to me i see look at that untouchable
Okay.
And then we slash in the sleepy time.
Okay, we're okay.
Okay, guys, guys, I'm not doing a shift again.
Okay, guys, the shift was a mistake.
The shift was absolutely a mistake.
I am not doing holding shift again.
I...
The shift might have been...
Might have been a mistake to do.
Guys, please do not throw rocks at Garfield.
I should have been more specific, but also please don't
punch Garfield too.
That was my bad.
I wasn't specific.
We didn't throw a rock, though.
Not a rock.
That is true.
You did throw rock paper...
Rock...
Rock, paper, scissors, though.
Pass the fairy!
Yay!
She gave me noodles.
Oh, nope.
I can't.
I shouldn't complain.
I'll hit food is food.
There's people starving in Africa, Tokyo.
Food is food.
You're right.
Oh, yay.
Noodles.
Yeah.
You're right.
People are starving.
driving in Africa and I've got food.
Pasta fairy is on a budget.
Can't keep feeding me, I guess.
It's not a soup kitchen.
Oh, okay.
Maybe I'll pray one more time.
Maybe.
Maybe, Pastor fairy.
Look, I don't...
Oh, thanks, guys.
Thanks.
I forgot the script.
No problem.
Welcome back.
Where is my butt?
Just a little A that touched me.
Alright.
Pookie time?
Okay, it's Pookie, it's still Pookie time?
Oh my god!
Pookie, please!
Oh, it's okay, it's okay.
It's a little...
Well, Pookie doesn't hurt anybody.
Well, it hurts me, but like, you know, it doesn't...
Okay, nice.
Can I master the odys?
The mode odys have been, you know, I'm gonna do a pray.
Maybe pass the fairy will come.
Oh, okay, okay Thanks guys Thanks Okay, there's honking to
support you Oh, okay.
Okay Okay Thank god.
Thank god.
I can move my toes Thank fucking god.
Okay, I'm just gonna You're welcome Hawk to support Doki
There's like no bumper stickers
All right, we're just gonna slash I gave you guys two
chances
Okay, oh my god a fucking course I gotta eat that spaghetti.
I'm so low All right, I can't keep getting handouts put in
the fairy.
She's gotta pay her own bills.
It's okay.
We still have half HP.
Oh, it's not sleep time!
That's right.
And that's them praying after this.
Nice.
Oh, God.
That was close.
Come on, pasta.
It doesn't matter.
At least, at least at that time.
At least you get sneak time.
There's a 50-50.
Oh, you're paralyzed?
That's like the Maddy!
Oh, that's the very baddies!
Yay!
Oh.
People in Africa are starving, Dookie.
People in Africa are starving.
You should be grateful.
Ten for noodles.
Wow nothing happened again okay I did get left on red I
don't understand some people pray every day but oh just
because I prayed like 20 times in a row I don't get anything
life's just so unfair and that's just rude I know so fucking
rude You're praying too much.
Oh, God.
I actually need a...
Oh, what am I going to do with 10 noodles?
Hello from Africa.
I had, like, three boxes of lasagna today.
I'm so stuffed.
What's she thinking of this?
Super chat.
Thank you.
Oh.
Guess I'm...
I'll pray another time.
You felt like someone was watching.
Yeah, okay.
God, I have to full focus every time I do that run.
It's so fucking stressful.
We were seen, but not heard.
Alright, spaghetti time.
And I have 10 noodles.
And then this here.
And then it's...
It was not there!
I don't know why I thought it was there.
Oh.
Okay.
That's fine.
I still have another noodle!
New the time!
Okay, here, then here, then here, and then BAM!
Okay, I know that one.
Alright, and then I get a freebie here, so I'm just gonna
pray and hope to- Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
That's...
This way.
Chop chop.
Okay, it doesn't matter what happens.
Like, it really doesn't.
Because I know what's going to kill me here.
Oh god.
I don't remember.
I don't remember this platter.
It's fine.
We still have three more newtas.
Alright.
Garfield with gun.
Here you go.
Ah!
Oh
I never believed That's the funny part I could tell I was
just delaying delaying the inevitable Delay my death.
I was marked.
I was already marked.
There was no saving me.
Okay.
Where is my butt?
Oh, are you serious?
Oh my god, move too fast there.
Okay, that's okay.
20 HP.
20 HP is not bad.
We pray.
we pray this is the moment yeah god
people keep my lasagna though
okay okay we have lasagna we have lasagna i couldn't spare
spaghetti oh my gosh she graced us with her presence
thank the lords i am now worthy i am worthy
Oh, thank God.
Okay, that's okay.
That's okay.
Sleep time.
She might come back.
Okay, that's okay.
That's okay.
That is more spaghetti for me.
I can eat a yum yum yum yum spaghetti.
Yummy spaghetti.
Okay.
Maybe I pray.
And she comes back with more.
hot lasagna oh that hurts me too but that that oh it's okay
it's okay it's oh forgot to wear a helmet
oh my god fucking course i stubbed my toe a fucking course
yeah that's the lasagna
can't complain look you can't complain she gave you like she
children are starving and she He gave you lasagna.
I'm just gonna eat the last spaghetti.
Food is food.
Kids in Africa, Doki, remember that.
Every time.
Takes so much out of my eyes.
Okay.
I don't remember the pattern for this one.
For the first one.
here and then it's the center oh my god okay i do remember
okay and i stand still here and i move
and then it's here and then it's here and i stay here
downloaded okay
I'm gonna risk it
He gives me a freebie I give him a freebie Look guys look he
did give me a freebie for this So I give freebie
So free guys So fucking free I know right Oh, my God.
The freest of...
I don't know.
I don't know how to get out of the dots.
I just...
I'm not strong enough.
I'm just not strong enough.
I forgot.
Okay, and then it's the center.
22.
Okay.
Fight!
Oh my god!
Wait!
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait!
Make it, make it, make it!
This is it!
Well, you got me.
That's too bad.
I didn't think I'd actually lose.
Oh well, do what you gotta do.
Kill.
Just kidding!
Did you really think you could beat me?
Don't make me chuckle.
What?
Cheer up, bud.
You made me use 10% of my power.
Now, I know what to do with naughty kittens like you.
You think you're so cute?
Hmm.
Well, enjoy being the cutest for all eternity.
What?
Oh, that's pretty cute.
Get stuff!
You turned me into a market for plushie.
What?
You...
I...
I don't...
Anything to...
do i even i don't even win i win but i
you did it thank you for the same chat thank you thank you
nobody wins field the only sands I can't even kill
yeah did I did I I did it he's too powerful all right well
look at the other endings I have the tabs anyway might as
well all right I'm not, I'm not, no, I don't know.
I got a really lucky run, guys.
I don't know if I can do that again.
I got an incredibly lucky run.
Bad Monday simulator.
All end, guys, there is no way we can, okay, all six
endings.
All right.
I'm going to use this one.
There we go.
It's like I'm playing, guys.
It's like I'm playing right now.
All right.
Where is...
Oh, is this the...
That's the one that...
Okay, this is the Mercy one.
All right.
Do we...
Okay, we don't count the ones on Halloween.
It technically took me...
Guys, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is my first time playing it.
It took me 14 times.
Never.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thanks, little buddy.
Maybe not so bad after all.
Let me repay you for your kindness.
By sending you on an all-exclusive vacation.
Okay, you know what?
Being a marketable plush is better than being...
Where am I sent to?
Welcome to Abu Dhabi.
Enjoy your new permanent home.
too right okay I think I think me and Marco plush is better
than being like sent like wrapped in a box with no water
bathroom or food and hoping I survived the plane ride oh
sent to mr.
Beastland but Doki you get to go to mr.
Beast oh that's true that never mind that is true I get I do
get to go to Beastland though all right let's see how he
does oh my god look how good i am guys watch this fab i'm
playing yeah i'm playing the game right now whoa i'm so good
whoa look at me go
we get to see Aladdin toky look at this guys whoa look at
that oh my god i know exactly where
I can hear my victims whispering.
Okay, watch this.
I've mastered it.
Look at that.
Whoa!
No hits!
Oh!
I'm so good at this game.
Look at that.
Let's look at the ending.
No hits, guys.
I'm incredible.
Yeah, see how I avoided the game?
gun
what was this ending oh wait mercy again you're sparing me
nirmal after all we've been through maybe just maybe we can
be friends wait it's the abby here you go a special present
for my new best friend oh it's new dialogue oh back to abby
back to...
Back to Abbey Dubai.
That was a Dubai.
Abbey Dubai.
You made me sweat a little bit.
Not gonna lie.
You made me use 10% of my power.
Too bad noinkins get what they deserve.
Enjoy the new home.
Alright.
Hard mode.
Spare.
Oh wait.
That's a different one.
All right, ending four.
I'm just pulling your leg.
I ain't losing to a degenerate like you.
This is unearned.
But now I got you right where I want you.
Your palace, I've seen through your every move.
With this Iron Man.
I'll grant you a little bit of mercy.
You can save being a cutest forever.
Enjoy your brand new body.
Yay!
I got to be cute forever.
I ain't so bad.
I mean, doing it in a plushie ain't so bad.
I like this catcrafted with hay.
And we have a three-year warranty, guys!
Look at that!
Guys, look, three-year warranty.
You barely get that for other stuff.
You gotta pay for that.
Yes.
This is like stolen valor.
That's it.
Doki, this is stolen valor.
What are you doing?
No, this is crazy.
The Monday difficulty, the one out of one?
Okay, I gotta see this.
Oh, wait, what?
You mean I could just stay there the entire time?
Holy shit.
Okay, that's crazy.
The 1 HP.
Whoa, what the fuck?
How is he doing this?
How?
I swear to God, Sandsfield was not this easy when I played
it.
Yeah, this is actually a hitless run.
I swear to god he hacked the game somehow to make the game
easier for him I swear to god there's no way
There's no way he he edited in code Obviously he downloaded
a different version
I'm like so impressed with like not getting hit on the pipe
though That's the ZZZ one.
Without getting hit.
That one's gonna be interesting.
Yeah, you can always pass through the cheese.
And, uh...
Oh, that's smart.
Because he knows exactly when he needs to sleep.
There you go.
What the fuck did he do?
What the fuck?
What?
Why is he not...
Oh, wait.
There's no point in praying.
So he's like purposely missing.
We did it, everyone.
We found the pipe.
That's so smooth.
Guys, he's hacking.
I swear to God.
This is a script.
He's using a script, guys.
I refuse to believe this is human.
Human touch.
He set up like those like,
um that like does stuff for your keys i forgot what it's
called like that program like you set up so that you can do
like uh special like you do like buttons faster like combos
and stuff faster macros yeah this guy has a macro check his
pc he's macroing
Yeah, tool assistant Tool assistant speed run right here
All right, but that one's easy I anyone could do that one
including me Guys that one was easy come on
Chomp chomp You got so lucky there Okay, I'm doing it right
now.
Yeah, yeah, I'm doing the hardest run right now.
This is me, obviously.
Not Stolen Valor or anything.
God, how could you guys think I would, like, fake a run?
Not Markiplier.
In FNAF.
Obviously.
I'm not Dream.
Oh, look at this, guys.
I finally figured out how to do this mode.
Under.
Look at that.
Yeah, Doki would never.
Exactly.
I'm Doki.
He stares into the camera.
Hmm.
Alright.
What did I get?
That's right.
I got.
Wow, I did it.
I beat it again.
Thanks, guys.
I know.
No hit run.
Wow.
I mean, of course I do it.
I'm high.
I'm a gamer.
Sairs into the camera.
I did it, guys.
Oh, now both resizer activate.
Please.
You're 100 years too early to be facing me.
What's the matter?
I'm giving up.
Have you been working out?
Whoa, you're so slow, bro.
I'm gay, but, bro, you're so slow.
Give me a break, yeah!
This really is the end, eh?
I've got to add it to you, Nerva.
You're an irredeemable monster.
Well, I'm not too sure you're Nerval anymore.
Arlene, Alphalus, Pookie, Odorus.
I couldn't avenge any of you.
He's become Monday.
Nerval is now.
Evil.
Oh my god, wait a second.
Statues crossed out, too!
I don't know if you guys see this, but Satisfil's statue
also, like, got chopped up.
Man, you think of Super Chat?
Thank you, thank you.
Don't keep watching every sequence in the no-hit run.
Yeah, that's what I would do.
Yeah, I know, right?
It's like how, like, when people watch, like, sports or
esports, like, yeah, I would have done something.
I wouldn't have done that.
Or, like, yeah, I would have done that differently, you
know?
Yeah, I could do that, too.
Oh my god!
Or maybe not.
It looks like your rat is here.
Prepare for a liftoff.
You're going to orbit, you stupid schmuck.
You'll have fun in other space.
It's cold and empty, just like you.
Okay, the kill option is definitely better than Mercy.
Nirm...
Because at least, like, Nirm will be...
Like, still lives.
Nirmal drifted endlessly through the space.
He's going through that more.
Oh, never mind.
He's drifting endlessly.
Because at least Nirmal can still be alive, even though he
kills everyone.
Eventually, Nirmal stopped thinking.
Yeah, that's why you never spare.
Don't worry.
There's still one more ending left that I got.
Naturally.
Where?
Oh.
Whoa.
What happened?
Where's the extra?
Oh, it's just credits.
Wait, that's not the ending.
Where?
Oh, we're just looking at the credits.
Oh, oh, he's on Twitter now.
Okay.
So that's not all the endings.
All right, let's find me.
Okay.
Oh, what's the end?
the secret ending?
Secret ending.
That's the ending.
Where's the...
Oh, there it goes.
Secret ending.
There we go.
Wait, is that the secret ending?
Where the fuck?
Where is that?
Where?
Wait, oh, it's here.
Oh, there you go.
I got it.
I have to tab out.
I have to, like, find it before I tab back in.
Alright, there you go.
But Nervo never stopped thinking.
Years began to pass.
Decades.
Centuries.
Oh, no.
He's going crazy.
But Nervo Nermal was still thinking...
Oh, Noki's cuckoo bananas!
What the fuck?
Uh...
Nermal?
Wait, this is not Jojo.
Nermal's body solidified in stone.
Space debris gathered and hardened.
You are still there.
Me?
What's going on?
Eon's path, space and time were meaningless.
Existence stretch onwards to infinity.
Is that a Jojo reference?
Yo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But there was a bright blue marble directly in your path.
You could hardly believe it.
Perfect.
What is he going to do?
Don't do it, Durba!
No!
He's gonna kill the dinosaurs!
The end.
Oh my god, he did it.
That wild man.
Bravo.
Well played, my little friend.
Bro, killed the dinosaurs.
The way you manipulate manipulate that Zansfield character
in the sending you in a space.
Jim Davis!
Little did he know.
He was perpetuating your existence for all eternity.
Dastardly, I'm a big fan.
Please continue to entertain me with your hilarious antics
and I'll be watched.
I knew it!
I knew Nirmal was his favorite character.
Why else would he torture us with his presence?
Oh my god.
Mr. Davis.
Yes, JD Gaster.
Oh, spooky.
Oh, my God.
How long is that today for you?
You became the very thing you swore to destroy.
You became Monday.
How could you, Tokey?
it i created monday and killed off the dinosaurs two for one
i got the two for one deal guys i fucking did it i feel so
betrayed i guess i'm an auntie now look jokey if it was just
the if it was just the dinosaurs then that's Fine, but you
have to create Monday still.
It was me, Godfield.
I did it all.
Melan's in the Super Chat.
Thank you.
What a way.
And then let's go back to the kitchen.
Hey, oh, where did my body go?
Okay, give me a second.
Don't worry, I can fix my body.
Give me a second.
Gotta fix my body real quick, guys.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Alright, that should be it.
I think that fixes it.
Yeah, there we go.
Now it looks less scary.
It's okay.
My body is fixed.
And now we'll have Halloween music played because I don't
want to find music right now.
So it's spooky Halloween BGM tab.
That's fun.
Honestly, I'm glad it did not take longer.
I'm really glad.
I'm glad that um because I'm pretty sure the version because
we played the older version so I'm pretty sure the version
we played in the end we threw one final rock that's true we
did in the end we we did end it with a rock in the end um
that's right I brought Mondays I'm very I think it's because
like the game because like the game we played on Halloween
was I think was the first version that Lumpy uploaded it so
like I'm I'm I'm uh they I think like people were like this
is so hard please please make it please patch it and I'm
pretty sure that's why he added like the the pasta fairy
because like thank fucking God thank God he added the pasta
airy i'm so happy we played the nerf version of this it's
like that it's like it's like silk song again where um where
people um i played it after they nerfed everything which was
nice thank you lumpy for being a merciful god uh i had a
great time thank god it didn't take a long i think i didn't
take me that long because i did a lot of long streams the
last two days so this i needed a two twofer today thank god
yay baby mode yippee i am no longer tired cheers everyone
baby mode thank god for that yuck yuck yuck yuck um he's
still wearing it i didn't take off his garfield outfit
because i want i i want to feel like my oh she is real so
he's still wearing it right now um i also i also bought him
a christmas sweater too i bought him a snoopy christmas
sweater as well so that's really cute i got him a ton of
toys you know i just wanted to get him an early christmas
present because like um i needed to buy like um um i wanted
to try out some new dog foods because like i didn't want to
buy the expensive ass fucking kidney care food anymore
because he's cured now technically.
I don't know.
They were like, technically he's...
They were like he's cured, even though they told me it was a
lifelong disease.
And then, like, I don't know.
I guess dad didn't realize it was a lifelong disease.
So then he cured himself for some shit.
So then I was like, all right, I'm gonna find, like, cheaper
food.
Because, like, now that I don't have to get prescription dog
food anymore, I'm gonna look for, like, try and see...
Yeah, he just tanked it.
So I went to the...
to the pet store to see if i can find like um like see what
kind of dog food i can get that's cheaper but also like is
like i also i still got wet dog food i just wanted like
something cheaper because they were very very expensive um
every week so i mean i did end up spending like 200 in the
end because i bought him a goddamn fucking sofa and um lots
of toys and also like lots of clothes and everything but you
know it's you know it's a little christmas gift for him i'm
tempted to throne account but i'm tempted to like like make
it keep it like dad only so if anyone wants to send um dad
any toys or anything like you guys can send him stuff um
because he's always destroying toys uh because he's a little
so i'll think about it because i know some of you guys like
sending dad like stuff like outfits and toys and stuff so
maybe i'll think about it um i mean it'd be like you know
it'd be cute you know i can show you guys photos of like
what you guys send over but i'll think about it i'll think
about it uh just make it just primarily dad like not for me
can we send dad a rice cooker no because he will not be
eating rice guys he's not gonna need a rice cooker guys um
um but yeah no i bought him like a bunch of toys.
I bought, oh my god, I like let him roam around the pet
store.
And then he kept trying, he kept finding balls like, like
that sneaked underneath like underneath the, what's it
called, the shelves.
Like I don't know how every time I was like, no, it's very,
it's so dirty.
Like he kept like going under the shelves and like finding a
new ball.
He found like four fucking balls that rolled under the shelf
and he like brought them to me.
I'm like, not buying this ball it's fucking disgusting and
he just he gets just like okay but i found another one
though yeah he's like a fucking ball detector i bought him a
ball and i went and bought him a ball like a clean one um uh
ron thank you the super chat thank you thank you thank you
boom thank you for the super chat thank you thank you thank
you oh yeah oh yeah by the way uh on Sunday we are going to
do a stream I might do a stream on Monday because on Tuesday
I don't know I'll be streaming on Monday but I might do a
stream on Monday just because on Tuesday I'll be at the
dentist and I don't know how what the fuck they're gonna do
to my mouth um because like I said um it's still it's not
like uncomfortable I mean it's just a little uncomfortable
because I could feel like something like on my top like it's
not the tooth I just feel something um so um because I don't
know if my gums are like the gum in that area is swollen as
well I can't tell because it's at the far back so um so on
Tuesday uh yeah on Tuesday I'll be at the dentist I have no
idea what they're gonna be doing to my mouth so that's why I
might be taking Tuesday and Wednesday off just in case and
then you know I don't want to be like suddenly talked like
if I if they do something to my teeth like I have to get
stitches or whatever um and then like or like they have to
like uh you know I don't I don't know what the fuck they're
gonna be doing on Tuesday.
So, um, I don't want to be like streaming on Wednesday and
then like, oh shit, guys, sorry.
I think I'm bleeding.
I think I'm bleeding out of my mouth right now because I
ripped the stitch or some shit.
Like, I don't want that to happen.
So, I don't be like, hey guys, hey guys, my mouth is
bleeding.
Whoops, gotta stop stream.
just in case and then maybe I'll come back on maybe on
Thursday it'll be fine um so wait actually let me double
check Tuesday Wednesday yeah cuz like oh that's awkward guys
I almost forgot this is a the most awkward time to like have
like dentist work on me because I almost forgot I have a
live session of my maid cafe on Friday and Saturday so let's
hope everything will be okay by then i can sing by friday uh
yeah i think it was like oh wait guys oh yeah let's hope
like let's hope i can sing by friday whatever the fuck they
decided to do to my mouth let's continue oh well then yeah
fingers crossed everyone fingers crossed Anyways, hey guys,
I'm Kali here.
We have tomorrow, uh, uh, tomorrow, Apex tournament with
Moxie and Wig.
It's not, like, super, it's not really, like, super try
hard.
It's just for fun.
Um, um, and, you know, I'm glad I was able to, uh, grab
Moxie and Wig on my team.
Um, I was like, are you down?
You're like, fuck yeah.
And I'm like, cool, sweet.
Uh, Moxie and Wig never interacted together before, but
They're both really funny people.
So Moxie and Wig were like, yeah, like Moxie's like, oh
yeah, Wig's fucking hilarious.
So I'd love to talk to him.
And Wig was like, yeah, he seems like a really funny guy.
So they both think they're, they both think they're, a lot.
English is hard if it's my first language.
They both think that the other person is funny.
So like, I hope we all have fun.
Moxie and I have not played Apex in a very fucking long
time.
I did play like two games of Apex a couple of days ago.
go um and i was like and then i won two games i won both the
games i played as alter bro alter is fucking pussy is such a
pussy fucking hero and i love it because i was playing alter
i was just like die on point i have res because like okay so
alter um up there was like basically her up she throws like
her alt thing down and you just send your two teammates out
into like out to die you literally wait at your like little
portal you wait at your portal and then you it's like
pokemon you send your two teammates out to die and the
moment they get knocked down you just freaking like bring
them back to the portal and then just res them and then like
i did that like seven times and it's unlimited too that's a
crazy part that you can do it Like, a non-stop.
I was like, bro, this is so dumb.
It's so fucking dumb.
So, and then, like, I was like, okay, I think I'm...
I'm think...
And I played two games, and I was like, yeah, I think I got
it.
And I went back to Rivalrous.
I definitely was not practicing.
I mean, I technically...
I did practice, guys.
I technically did practice.
I was just like, okay, I think I get it.
And then I went and booted up Marvel Rivalrous.
I don't know.
I think they made the game too easy.
That's the only thing.
I think that's why I couldn't, I didn't, like, play longer.
Because I think they made the game way too easy now.
It's definitely very, I didn't realize how casual coded the
game is now for Apex.
Because, like, they have a tutorial on how to Mantle Boost.
For those who don't know what Mantle Boost is, was really
really hard to mantle boost and you have to like time it
correctly and everything i logged in i logged in the apex
and they're like would you like to have the mantle boost ui
on your screen and i was like what the fuck what i was just
so because by the way i haven't played apex like the actual
apex apex in like more than almost a year i think i think i
think so and i like i was like oh my god there's like a
little tutorial on your screen like every time you like
every time you climb something up the you there's a ui
that's like remember the press space now if you want a
mantle boost i'm like it's so weird i have it on because of
course i'll i'll take advantage of that i was never
consistent in mantle boosting so i was like oh yeah fuck
yeah let me yeah i'm it's I'm baby I was like fuck yeah I'm
baby I need I need a step-by-step tutorial game I like yeah
I need those training wheels let me in fact let me give me
four training wheels this is not a tricycle anymore I need
like four of them it's just a car now.
I fucking, I made a car.
So, Moxie also hasn't played Apex in a year as well.
So, good luck, nice wig.
You're the IGL.
Our team name is washed GGs.
Yeah, I came up with that team.
I love coming up with team names, but that's my team name.
Washed GGs.
Because I know like, you know, whenever we die, you guys can
be like washed GGs.
It's fitting The name of chance Yeah, yeah Whenever we die
You guys can be like Watched GGs Yeah, I'm very aware I'm
not Very aware Bro, oh my god So The tournament It was
supposed It's like It's supposed to be like So like there's
three tiers So it's like good at Apex or in like casual
slash noob.
And I was just like, I looked at it and I was on the middle.
And I was like, and but then I saw people in the third
category that was like that plays Apex a lot still or like,
um, and or like has hit masters and stuff.
And I was like, why am I not in the third category?
Like, because I was like, I haven't touched Apex in a year.
be in the third category and then and then it was very hard
i understand because it was very hard it must be very hard
to balance and they were like well um you still hit like you
do like hit top 500 in rivals and i'm like but like that's
third person though i was just like but i was like i have
been in a couple also i have in a couple of seasons either
but like they're just there i mean it makes sense because
they said their justification was that um i'm able to take
instructions very well and I have good game sense, which is
like, you know, it's understandable because like I have good
game sense and so, and I can still like semi IGL.
So that's why they put me in the middle, but I was just
like, but then like, they're also like, oh, um, in the third
category, like I was just like, wait, but some of these
players, they're still playing Apex or like, but they're
like, yeah, but this person didn't play for a whole season
for last season.
So that's why they're in the third category this they
haven't played a lot and I'm like I haven't played in a year
Oh, they haven't played for one whole season now.
I'm like I haven't played in a year
That's a joke guys.
I thought it was just funny.
I was just like what
season like but yeah yeah boohoo one whole season that they
didn't play yeah I just thought that was really funny I was
just like what the fuck um um but I understand the
justification while in the middle category just because like
my experiences I guess like my experience isn't competitive
in various games I can just pick things up really fast but I
don't know I don't know it's very for me it's also like it's
also like there's so much pressure too on me with it because
there's always like so much high expectation being like oh
you know just because like she's very competitive and she
always does like she tries so hard and stuff like that so it
always has a lot of pressure and stuff because i'm just like
oh why am i i thought i was like i thought i would like you
know they put me i would eventually get a lower tier
You know, I thought eventually I'll be put in the third
category, third tier, you know?
I was just like, I haven't even, bros, I haven't even
touched rank in so long.
Some of these people have hit masters like a couple, like
two or two seasons ago.
I think I've been like hard stuck bronze because I haven't
touched rank that long.
Oh, no, never mind.
There's like placements now.
My SBMM is gold, apparently, which is crazy because I
haven't touched rank in a year.
Like I haven't even touched rank in a year.
Since Rivals came out.
I haven't touched rank since then.
Yeah.
So I thought that was like...
I don't think I'll ever...
I don't think I'll ever be put in a lower tier category no
matter what.
That's a funny connection.
They remember the war crimes you committed.
in the hide-and-seek tournament.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Will, thank you for the super chat.
Y'all put a higher because you are in Minnesota.
Psychological warfare is worse than competing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And then, like, I did appreciate that.
They let me get Moxie as my third.
Because I said, like, oh, I was like, oh, I do feel a little
uncomfortable because, you know, I did.
I did say, like, you know, I don't have, I haven't had much
experience in the game in a very long time so i'm out of
meta you know i'm out of meta i don't know what's meta
anymore i mean i did hit like effect i asked effect about
like what the meta is and like what players to play what
characters to play um but even then i felt like you know i
did i was like oh i did feel a little uncomfortable um as
the second tier so i was wondering if i could for the third
tier like if i could get like moxian like he doesn't have a
lot of apex experience like he hasn't played in a year but
he can aim he does have really good aim so like so would
that be like okay to do you know like because like it's like
exchange between like he doesn't have a lot experience but
he can aim is that is that okay and they're like yeah that's
okay like that can we can have that since like um it would
balance everything out and everything so i'm like yay and
he's and i'm like you know the team has good vibes i think i
hope i hope the team will are like vibe people we're all
we're all like very vibey it was either moxie or tempo but i
don't think like me and wig kid um mental would be okay with
that again for i i like i don't know i i love i love tempo
though he's fucking fun like as the besties with all three
of us yeah i don't want to babysit right now i love playing
with the besties though i do love playing but then like i
felt like the tournament had a lot of like try hearts um it
is a casual tournament it's not like a really big prize pool
it's more like geared towards for fun and um it's more
geared towards for fun and everything so i was like fuck it
i haven't played the apex in a while and i miss playing with
wig And he was down too.
He's literally coming back from the Red Bull tournament as
well.
Which was really cool because, like, I asked the organizers
if I could get Wig.
And they're like, oh, are you sure Wig can do it?
Because a lot of people who are doing the Red Bull
tournament was like, oh, no, nice Wig.
Nice Wig.
They're saying that, oh, a lot of people doing the Red Bull
tournament, they're not going to be able to come to the
VTuber Apex tournament.
Or, like, not just VTuber.
like slash pro tournament it's like a mix um and i asked wig
and i was like oh are you down and he's like yo fuck yeah
bro i'm fucking down i was like are you gonna make it in
time because you're i know you're like traveling for red
bull he's like yeah yeah i can make it so cheers um uh
what's the word uh uh big big ups for wig for being able to
make it despite having just traveling back from the yeah
being a bro for being able to come back in time for the
tournament as well because he's doing this for fun as well
with me you know i assume the red bull plate paid him a lot
of fucking money to do the red bull tournament um because
it's fucking red bull uh yeah yeah cheers to him yeah being
homie um and uh uh cheers the moxie too for uh willing to
play with me again uh for the tournament as well because i
know he's a very busy guy as well um since he's like he does
you know for those who don't know who moxie is he's like
friends with um like xqc and a lot really really big
streamers and everything so he handles a lot of stuff for
xqc sometimes and so um and also he has his own streaming
career with rivals too so uh big ups to moxie too for uh
playing this for fun with me because i told him like the
prize pool isn't that much uh like are you still down and
he's like bro of course and he was like yeah of course well
i love to i love to do out with you guys and I'm like yay I
was like yippee because it's just we're just doing this for
fun not doing this to win anything or like for prize money
it's just to hang out um so yeah because I think like I
think like first place is I think the first place is like I
think it's like a thousand but it's like you know it's
there's it's so hard like it's a thousand divided by three
players too Like I said, um, you know, that's why I'm, like,
cheers to them for, like, giving their time to play with me,
um, for this, for a fun tournament.
Um, you need to put up an over- No, no, I'm pretty sure I
don't.
I'm pretty sure.
But, yeah, it's at 12 p.m.
PST, by the way.
I almost forgot to tell you guys.
Tomorrow's tournament is at 12 p.m.
PST.
Put up the thumbnail whenever- the waiting room, whenever,
um, um, my thumbnail maker finishes it.
Because I forgot to give it the details until like this
morning So like I've been so tired lately that my manager
has been uploading my like all my waiting rooms in the last
week and a half Because I've been so tired So so cheers to
my manager too That's why I always sometimes I forget to
turn off like rewind because of it because he makes the
waiting room So yeah that's why my waiting room tweets are
also like super late Because sometimes I, like, just tweet
it out whenever I wake up.
And sometimes I wake up really late.
So, yeah.
Thanks, manager.
Yeah.
But I'll see you guys tomorrow at 12 p.m.
PSC.
For those who want to watch the Apex tournament, I have no
idea how we're going to do.
But our team is called Wash GG.
So we're going.
You're getting what you're getting.
You're getting.
McProp's, you shout out to the organizers for that
tournament.
Because, you know, organizing tournaments is a lot of work.
There's a lot of balancing stuff they have to do and
everything.
And they, like, put up with all my questions about, like,
balancing stuff.
And us also, because, like, you know, like, when I was,
like, asking, like, wait, why am I in tier two?
And they're, like, you know, the reason he gave me was,
like, oh, yeah, I get it.
I mean, I did just one, the Rivals tournament, too.
I'll get it like even though I'm rusty in apex I feel like
game sense you don't really lose game sense um because like
game sense can travel game sense like travels between like
you know between games um it's very easy to like pick up
very fast so I understand um I might be like my aim might
not be as good though I will have to admit I think some
people in tier the tier three category might have better aim
than me because i was like first person what the fuck is
that i was just like what the fuck is first person oh my god
everything is so close to me i swear i swear i was like
aiming i'm like oh my god they're like in my face is so
weird like um fps what the fuck
yeah why are my eyes in my head why can't I see my ass um
this is insulting I can't see my ass what's the point I this
is stupid yeah why no third person but my FSVTuber what
happened to her what happened to her just like my personal
space um um but yeah but yeah i look forward to it uh i hope
i could i'll do okay um but yeah even though i'm put on the
second category just letting you guys know um i think i
played apex less than um definitely not as much as i should
have for this tournament but we're here to have fun We have
a very fun team going in, so I'm just happy to hang out with
my friends too.
Yep.
I'm just happy that...
I'm happy we made a really fun team to play with.
So I'm happy to talk to them again.
It's been a while.
It's been a while since I've talked to Wig, and it's been a
while since I've talked to Moxie.
Yeah, anyway, guys.
As always, everybody, say hi, Jory Day, Pasha Check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
I'm used to it for me at the bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everyone.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Whoa.
Bonus ending.
Because the moment I swapped, Dad started barking.
Let's see if I can bring him over.
Oh, he stopped barking because I started talking.
He's like, wait, I thought you ended stream.
Why are you like...
I thought you ended stream.
Why did...
Why are you talking?
Yeah, never mind.
He stopped barking.
Oh, do you guys hear him?
Do you guys hear him?
Do you guys hear that?
Yeah, he started barking the moment I went to the ending
screen.
Anyway, guys, bye.